katia bonjour quel est donc le programme
d'aujourd'hui
alors tout d'abord l'audience a démarré
à 13h30 aujourd'hui là nous sommes
devant la trente deuxième chambre
c'est l'audience du procès fillon et
seront examinés aujourd'hui les
questions de détournement de fonds
publics par une personne dépositaire de
l'autorité publique
les questions de complicité et de recel
et en question bien sûr cette mission
d'assistante parlementaire présumées
fictives ou tout au moins sur évalué un
million d'euros c'est la somme qu'a
touché pénélope fillon pour ce travail
ce travail supposé alors aujourd'hui
l'audience a démarré avec une prise de
parole des époux filles ont tout d'abord
pénélope fillon qui a expliqué qu'elle
avait délibérément minimisé son rôle en
regard de ce qui se passait en grande
bretagne car les épouses des premier
ministres là bas ont un rôle d'influencé
elle s'implique et elle at elle dit
souhaiter rester dans les affaires
locales
ensuite françois fillon françois fillon
lui s'est plaint que tout le monde
essaie de de se souvenir vario de
dossier qui date de 40 ou 35 ans 35 ans
et que évidemment ne s'en souvenait pas
éventuellement du titre mais pas du
contenu
si quelque chose semblait faire
consensus c'était le niveau de
rémunération de pénélope fillon de 19 à
24 euros selon les années et cela semble
correspondre en effet à son expérience
professionnelle et à son niveau de
diplôme en revanche le procureur et les
avocats de la défense se sont opposés
notamment sur une diffusion d'un numéro
d'envoyé spécial les avocats de la
défense ne veulent pas que celui qu'il
soit projeté ils ont demandé qu'on en
termine avec le tribunal médiatique et
qu'on examine enfin les pièces et les
témoignages
il sait il s'avère que des témoins vont
en effet se présenter cet après midi
pour expliquer que pénélope fillon a
bien travaillé qu'il ya des traces de
son activité
voilà en ce qui concerne ce début
d'audience et nous vous tiendrons au
courant au fil de la journée
katia merci pour toutes ces précisions